I'm Gary Stevenson, former trader
and people's economist, welcome
back to Gary's economics today we
are going to talk about recessions
okay so there was a big report out by the IMF (the
international monetary fund) um in the last couple
of weeks saying that the UK is going to avoid
a recession and this was reported in a lot of
the media the BBC basically all the major news
outlets so I wanted to talk a little bit about
what a recession is and really more than
anything why this way of understanding the
economy is is not very helpful and perhaps even
somewhat damaging so a recession is very narrowly
defined it's a technical economic phenomenon
which means two consecutive quarters of negative
economic growth um for this reason I think it's a
little bit stupid to focus on things like narrowly
missing a recession right the first reason is
you could have one quarter of negative growth and
one quarter of very slightly positive growth and
officially that means you've missed the recession
it's really the difference between having
-0.1% growth and +0.1% growth
um really in one case you've had a recession
in one case you've missed the recession
and the difference to your life is basically
completely invisible so this focus on whether
we technically get a recession or not is pretty
ridiculous um the second thing is that really
whether we have a recession or not it's
totally possible that your life is getting
worse whilst we are technically not in recession
I think the best example of that is in the 2008
crisis the recession officially ended in themiddle
of 2009 and yet the the 10-15 years since2009
have seen some of the biggest and fastest
falls in living standards for ordinary people
in the history of the country in peacetime um
you know in the 10 years after 2010 especially
after the election of the the conservative
coalition austerity government we saw
massive falls in living standards technically
that was not a period of recession and
um what this connects to is something we've
mentioned in previous videos right which is
recession is only a measure of what is happening
to GDP which is the overall size of the economy so
if you have an economy which is growing slowly but
becoming much more unequal you could easily have
what we have had which is living standards rising
for the richest whilst they fall for most ordinary
people so I think this focus on a recession
is somewhat absurd I think it reveals the
ridiculous the ridiculous or technocratic approach
that a lot of economists in the media have because
really whether we have a recession or not it
doesn't make any difference, you know technically
we've not been in a recession the last couple of
years and yet what has happened to ordinary living
standards? well they've absolutely collapsed so you
should be focused on living standards for yourself
for your family, your community and you shouldn't
really worry about whether we're technically
in a recession or not, but I think whatis
more damaging than the basic irrelevance
of whether we're in a recession, is the fact that
the framing of this economic crisis as a recession
could quite possibly lead to significant further
economic deterioration and the reason I say that
is that when you frame this economic crisis
this "cost of living crisis" as a recession
people understand that to meana kind
of temporary fallin living conditions
people think that recessionsare things
that you go through, they last a period
of time, you come out of them and then things
get better; that is not what is going to happen
in this crisis right things have gotten
significantly worse really really quickly
that rate of extremely rapid decline I think will
slow down but things will continue to get worse
over the next two, three, five, ten years and that
is because we have a fundamental problem in the
core of our economy, of rapidly increasing wealth
inequality, which is not being fixed so this is
not a crisis which is bad and then gets better
this is a crisis which is bad and then gets worse
and I know that for sure because you can see
that the massively growing problem of the wealth
distribution which has gotten massively worse
inthe last 3-4 years, is not get getting fixed,
will not be fixed and will continue to get worse,
so by calling this economic crisis a recession
it's as if, you've got cancer and the media is
calling it a cold, they're saying look you've
got a temporary problem, take some rest,
drink some water, things will get better
but that is not what is needed here because if
they say that and if you believe that then the
fundamental underlying crisis of growing and
growing wealth inequality, of falling living
standards, of the death of the middle class, all
the things that we've been talking about on this
channel will not get resolved, and furthermore
it means that there will be no impetus to talk
about or fix the massive amount of wealth the 700
billion pounds that has gone from the government
to the richest people in the country in the
last couple of years, so whenever you hear the
media talking about 'we're in a recession, we
missed a recession or we're out of recession'
ignore it and and ask them: what are you doing
about wealth inequality? what are you doing
about the massive increase in wealth inequality
in the last 3 years? the enormous, the fastest
ever increasing wealth of the richest people in
the country, the 700 billion pounds that has gone
from the government to the richest, when you're
fixing these things? um yeah don't listen to the
media talking about recession, focus on inequality
because that is what's going to matter if you
don't fix it; things will get worse. If we do fix it;
things will get better, so ignore the recessions
follow the money and demand that your politicians
fix wealth inequality and that your media start
talking about it more and economists as well,
don't let them off because they're useless, thank
you support the channel help us reduce wealth
inequality, help us prevent this economic disaster
if we don't do anything things will get worse so
um we have to do stuff to make it better! thank you